hey Greg knuckles here gonna walk you
through my past couple training sessions
this is from three days ago this is a
warm-up at 3:15 I talked about all the
time how my warmup sets especially on
squats I about only on squats I let the
bar bounce up off of my shoulders and
that's how I know I'm exerting enough
effort it's kind of like weight lifting
how you don't try to push through your
toes at the top of the lift but if
you're moving fast enough you'll just
automatically finish up on your toes
same general concept that next one was
four ninety five pretty easy what you
see now is bench obviously this is 360
and my wife is pushing down on the bar
during the East century to overload that
weights have just been feeling heavy in
my hands and so she's probably pushing
down with about a hundred pounds of
force or so so feels feels like lowering
for sixty but comes on up easy enough
this is a very very long post squat 315
for about a minute in 15 seconds or so
I've talked about breathing pause squats
before and why I like them I'll link
that video in the description that
side-to-side motion you see there that
very little spinal rotation spinal
rotation under heavy load is not a smart
thing that motion was coming mainly from
hip abduction and abduction just trying
to stretch out down there so yeah don't
don't see that and think it's a good
idea to try to do windmills at the
bottom of a squat with a heavy bar on
your back yeah this goes on for a little
while longer
oh also as you can see the left side of
the bars dipping down a little more I've
been having some left elbow issues my
squat low bar so that may contribute
I'll be I'll be focusing more on trying
to make sure my left side stays up level
with my right side this is from two days
ago now here's 4:15 for a double Peck
tendons were feeling a little bit beat
up from the heavy centric work from the
night before
but the 415 moved well and the drop back
work was all pretty fast
and then on to squats this is high bar
515 this is probably the best that this
weight has felt especially with a pause
which was kind of unexpected but I'll
definitely take it and the next this was
585 I kind of do math I thought it was
605 until someone told me before the set
so whatever but I will say because I'm
using the Olympic plates and not regular
45s the bar looks much more aesthetic
this way because you get the nice flow
of colors just just makes me happy do
this for a set of four I think I
probably had six or seven in me if I
wanted them but since I'm trying to up
my training frequency now that I have a
little more time to live I'm staying a
little further from failure on a
day-to-day basis just so I'm not so beat
up I can't train more often I finish
that off with deadlifts 25 singles I
started every minute on the minute but
that was too easy so I switched every 30
seconds well that's it thanks guys
please like and subscribe